[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce premier set
8 lipdo de l'année 2020 ensemble nous
ferons le tour de l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 10 janvier comme
chaque année l'association yvelines
environnement lance son défi pour les
jeunes département thématiques pour 2020
autour de l'eau nouveau record pour
l'entreprise rothaine l'entrepreneuriat
en 2019 et d'autant plus dans les
yvelines nous décrypterons cette
information officialisation du nouveau
centre aqualudique de maurepas y est
long cours l'université saint quentin en
yvelines entame son processus de
rapprochement avec paris saclay et le
secrétaire d'état aux transports en
déplacement à toussus le noble
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué le
département cette semaine et avant de
commencer cette édition un anniversaire
il ya son temps le traité de versailles
était promulguée
un traité de paix signé nous signer six
mois auparavant à la galerie des glaces
du château de versailles
nous y avons justement consacré 1 le 7 8
dossiers au mois de juin
il est à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile et
on démarre avec ce défi annuel lancé
jeudi par l'association yvelines
environnement
elle a donné le top départ de son
traditionnel concours jusqu'au 4 avril
le jeu est dédié aux jeunes yvelinois de
5 à 15 ans et aux personnes en foyer
d'hébergement principe les participants
devront remplir une grille de mots
complètent et d'un dessin a réalisé sur
le thème notre ami lot de tous les jours
le bulletin d'inscription est disponible
dans les établissements scolaires du
département aux accueils de loisirs
ainsi que sur demande à tous les
guichets sncf des yvelines interview
collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude
cette année nous avons choisi l'eau et
notamment l'eau du robinet
sur lequel il y à de nombreuses choses à
dire et aussi apprendre aux enfants que
l'environnement se peuvent être des
gestes simples et que quand on se brosse
les dents par exemple au lieu de laisser
le robinet couler à flots on peut
prendre tout simplement un verre et
fermer son robinet ce qui économise
l'eau qui est un élément essentiel de la
vie
[Musique]
jeudi s'est déroulée la quatrième
manifestation interprofessionnelle
contre le projet de réforme des
retraites
18 cars cgt des yvelines se sont rendus
dans le cortège parisien qui
comptabilisait cinquante six mille
personnes selon le ministère de
l'intérieur trois cent soixante dix
mille selon le syndicat trois cents
personnes se sont également rassemblées
à mantes la jolie et 50 aux mureaux
toujours selon la cgt la cgt 78 qui
annonce d'ores et déjà une nouvelle
manifestation le jeudi 7 janvier à
vélizy le 11 décembre dernier le medef
78 élu son nouveau président zacharie
hardy succède à bertrand de créer avec
lui une nouvelle équipe et six
vice-présidents zakaria redit qu'ils
devaient être présents sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui mais pour des raisons de
santé il a annulé sa venue
mélanie poké nicolas d'andry l'avait
interviewé au moment de son élection je
vous propose de l'écouter
les axes prioritaires c'est les
adhésions parce qu'il faut développer
les adhésions le deuxième axe c'est les
mandats les mandats de madame je me
défile vite j'ai à peu près une centaine
de demandes a dans le département
nous avons également l'animation du
territoire la fidélisation de nos
adhérents nous avons également la
communication et le digital également
nous avons
l'animation des commissions nous avons
également un autre axe prioritaire qui
celui de l'organisation et du contrôle
interne
voilà donc tous ces thèmes là qui vont
être un peu notre priorité pour la
prochaine mandature de trois ans nicolas
gandrille de la rédaction de tv 78 nous
a rejoint un plateau bonjour bonsoir
lui-même alors avec vous nous allons
parler entrepreneuriat avec un nouveau
record plus de 750 mille entreprises ont
été créées en france en 2019 une
augmentation de plus de 16% sur un an
nicolas retrouve le même phénomène dans
le département dans la région une
tendance similaire même plus forte que
au niveau national regarder cette
infographie sur l'évolution des
créations d'entreprises sur ces dix
dernières années à partir de 2015 la
courbe des créations d'entreprise en ile
de france s'envole elle passe au dessus
de celle au niveau national une
augmentation plus importante qu au
niveau national maintenant si on prend
au niveau des yvelines l'évolution est
similaire les chiffres de l'insee montre
que en 2019 plus de 18000 500 sociétés
ont été créées soit une hausse de 9,2
pour cent par rapport à 2018
et si on compare 2018 à 2017 les
créations d'entreprises se sont
fortement accrues à hauteur de 19 87%
alors comment peut-on expliquer le
succès des créations d'entreprises est
bien marienne plusieurs facteurs un
justifie cette augmentation depuis ces
dernières années
tout d'abord la simplification des
procédures pour créer son entreprise
c'est plus facile de créer son
entreprise
on est accompagné aussi plus fortement
qu auparavant avec des structures comme
le ski cube sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya aussi des aides financières qui
sont proposées par l'état et les
collectivités aux entrepreneurs les taux
d'intérêt bas aussi favorisent l'accès
au crédit pour lancer un projet
d'affaires
enfin il ya une évolution aussi dans la
société de nombreux salariés ne veulent
plus du salariat ils veulent se lancer
dans l'entreprenariat et
l'entrepreneuriat c'est aussi une
solution pour les demandeurs d'emploi et
donc réduire le chômage
ce phénomène est il a nuancé peut-être
effectivement marylène c'est positif
les créations d'entreprises permettent
de booster l'économie mais
l'entrepreneuriat c'est une aventure
c'est des risques pris par les créateurs
d'entreprise avec parfois des
défaillances pour les activités lancées
c'est à dire que toutes les créations
d'entreprises ne sont pas forcément des
success stories comme on dit dans
l'économie et quand le projet
fonctionne se construit il n'y a pas
forcément des revenus immédiats le
créateur d'entreprise peut avoir des
difficultés au début à se payer soi même
et donc un chiffre qui permet de montrer
cela le revenu moyen des micro
entrepreneurs actifs n'étaient que 2 470
euros par mois en 2010 est selon les
chiffres de l'insee
merci nicolas landry ou pas ça reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi par
des employés d'entreprises du territoire
c'est l'objectif de la job academy
organisée par la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion
plusieurs mois de rencontre grâce à des
parrainages une nouvelle édition se
tient jusqu'au 31 janvier avec un
nouveau partenaire
le département des yvelines qui s'est
lancé en novembre dernier dans sa
première job academy
mélanie poker aurélie rose ont suivi
l'une des filles elle va l'argent deux
fois par mois depuis le mois d'octobre
anne charlotte et sandrine se rendent
compte rentrer ma reine et fille anne
charlotte est demandeuse d'emploi mère
de quatre enfants elle cherche à
reprendre son parcours professionnel
c'est plus un projet professionnel en
fait que je viens chercher parce que je
suis un peu perdue devant l'étendue et
puis peut-être pas très sûr de moi étant
donné que j'ai pas trahi pendant
quelques années j'ai une formation
juridique donc ça pourrait être le
juridique mais
et voilà je suis ouverte à beaucoup de
choses aussi sandrine et salariés des
yvelines comme 11 autres membres de la
structure elle s'est portée volontaire
pour participer à une job academy
une première pour l'établissement
départemental je suis assez intéressé
par l'accompagnement les questions liées
à l'emploi m'intéresse et puis j'ai j'ai
eu la curiosité de l'autre et je trouve
qu'on se nourrit aussi beaucoup de
l'expérience de l'autre et ils sont
vraiment ils surfent 1 de l'ensemble de
nos directions nous avons des
travailleurs sociaux des personnes de
leur âge des systèmes d'information nous
avons même des personnes de la direction
générale des services donc voit un large
panel de nos métiers
elle la job academy ce sont aussi des
ateliers en groupe 4 mois des changes
professionnelle initiée par face
yvelines la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion
comment on arrive chacun d'entre nous à
surmonter une épreuve parce que il ya
toujours un moment dans la vie où on
manque de confiance en soi partage de
moments difficiles ou d'espoirs lors de
la recherche d'un emploi un moyen de
trouver des clés techniques et morales
est ce qu'on appelle nous aller vers une
meilleure employabilité
c'est ce qu'il va donner cette impulsion
par un accompagnement qui est
personnalisé mais qui surtout fait dans
le cadre de l'entreprise atelier des
changes mais aussi ateliers pratiques ce
matin la simulation d'entretien est
faite par un membre des ressources
humaines et une marraine anne charlotte
postule à une offre d'emploi de juristes
des droits des affaires on a
l'impression passer un vrai entretient
donc c'est bien c'est un bon ça booste
et ça ça aide à se préparer ça motive et
puis elles m'ont donné aussi plein de
petits trucs elles m'ont dit aussi ce
qui n'allait pas et sur lequel il
fallait travailler un peu donc non c
très constructif dans quelques jours
anne charlotte retrouvera sa marraine
pour finaliser son projet professionnel
la job academy se termine le 31 janvier
sur les douze filles l'accompagné six
ont déjà trouvé un emploi
et lundi le secrétaire d'état aux
transports jean baptiste g paris s'est
rendu à l'aérodrome de toussus le noble
objectif valoriser les innovations
aéronautique compatible avec les
engagements écologiques et
environnementaux pris par le
gouvernement notamment lors de la cop 21
il a pu essayer l'avion électrique alpha
électro et découvrir les moteurs propres
développé par la statue la start up show
boat est qu on les couteaux micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est donc au travers des discussions
que j'ai eues ici la conviction que nous
serons inventé en france un modèle qui
réconciliera à la fois l'écologie
l'industrie les territoires et le
progrès ce qui dans les temps que nous
connaissons actuellement me paraît au me
paraissent tout à fait à propos les
ville d'elancourt et maurepas se sont
rassemblés lundi matin pour signer le
contrat de construction et de gestion du
futur centre aqualudique
après deux ans de négociations le centre
sera finalement construit sur le terrain
de l'ancienne piscine avec les
équipements castelia les détails par
mathilde denis
ils encourent et maurepas bénéficieront
d'un taux de ce nouveau centre
aqualudique le contrat de délégation de
service public vient d'être signé un
soulagement pour le maire de maurepas
qui attend ce projet depuis cinq ans on
arrive au bout d'un long projet qui
avait démarré depuis 2015 on a perdu du
temps à cause de conflits politiques
inutiles 1 2 ans il aurait pu être livré
beaucoup plus tôt voilà aujourd'hui la
finalité est là on propose aux élans
courtois comme on mord pas y an un
équipement
ludique un centre aqualudique composé de
plusieurs espaces santé et bien-être qui
sera accessible pour les habitants des
deux communes un projet qui se veut
ambitieux et qui veut moderniser les
équipements sportifs de la ville
aujourd'hui le résultat est là ça va
être aussi certainement un modèle aussi
d'expérimentation parce que beaucoup de
villes dans en france ont ce problème il
ya une obsolescence aujourd'hui du
patrimoine notamment en ce qui concerne
d'équipement des piscines caste alias
est le nom de ce centre aqualudique un
projet intercommunal qui s'adapte à
l'environnement le chantier va durer 21
mois
donc avec une livraison prévue en avril
on a à peu près 140 mille heures de
travail sur ce chantier
en effectif de pointe où vous avez
raison on va être à peu près qu'une
petite centaine à peu près 90 personnes
on a prévu un effectif de points donc ça
va faire du monde sur ce site
fectivement mais voilà pour un bel
ouvrage à la fin les gros travaux
commenceront dans six mois coût de cette
réalisation un peu plus de 24 millions
d'euros le 5 novembre 2019 l'université
paris saclay a été créé par décret celui
ci est entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier
cet établissement dont trois universités
la composent avec parmi elles
l'université saint quentin en yvelines
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines de grands organismes de
recherche comme le cnrs sont également
associés à cette nouvelle entité
l'objectif de paris saclay de devenir la
première université française et figurer
dans le top 20 mondial des universités
cette fusion devrait devenir effective
en 2025 et accueillir 80 mille étudiants
on écoute le président de l'ue fait est
ce qu elle induit plus vs küssel même si
elle est très performante comme le
montre son classement récurrent dans le
classement de shanghai où elle figure
dans le top 500 et parmi les 20
meilleures universités françaises ou
même dans certaines disciplines parmi
les deux meilleures mondiales en
sciences de l'atmosphère par exemple
c'est que pour elle vient apporter tout
son potentiel à ce nouveau consortium
est aussi profiter d'une marque nouvelle
université paris saclay qui va lui
permettre de se développer un saut
générationnel et on passe des étudiants
à la petite enfance tout au long de
l'année des séances de contes destinés
en priorité aux 03 ans sont proposés
dans les médiathèques la caméra de
grégory kahn a laissé glisser à l'un de
ces états de ses ateliers à la
médiathèque le château à plaisir
les très célèbres asticots doigt entre
en scène
s'amuser avec les mots les rythmes
ce samedi matin les racontines ont pris
possession de la médiathèque le château
à plaisir ces séances de contes et de
continents musique s'adresse en priorité
aux 03 ans moi je suis une grande
lectrice son parti on aime beaucoup la
baie aller à la bibliothèque on y va
tous les mercredi et le samedi
régulièrement on participe à des et des
ateliers et octave j'aime beaucoup lire
ses livres tout seul dans sa chambre si
pour être au calme le soir par exemple
cet atelier proposé par une association
de voisins-le-bretonneux la portée
musicale destinée à favoriser l'éveil du
tout petit il dure une trentaine de
minutes
je propose dix huit à dix baptistes
séquences et c'est aussi dans la
répétition pour permettre à l'enfant
d'être dans son rythme
et s'il n'a pas envie de participer tout
de suite c'est les plus observateurs il
va attendre
et puis la répétition va lui permettre
de rentrer dans le jeu au fur et à
mesure chaque page de l'album est
prétexte à trouver un jeu une chanson ou
une manipulation d'instruments
[Musique]
c'est intéressant dans le sens où elle
déjà de travailler son imagination de
pouvoir découvrir le livre d'avoir un
rapport avec les mots de les comprendre
et que nous en fait on puisse voilà
essayer de travailler là dessus a vécu
une autre approche de la lecture pour
les tout petits proposées tout au long
de l'année par les médiathèques saint
quentinois et les comptes sont justement
à l'honneur du 15 janvier au 1er février
à saint quentin en yvelines le réseau
des médiathèques organise sa 19e fête de
compte le 7-8 culture du mardi 7 janvier
y était largement consacrée vous pouvez
le retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile
côté sport il n'y a plus de club
yvelinois en coupe de france versailles
est tombé face à granville en 32e de
finale 2 buts 1 à domicile
deux mille supporters sont venus
assister au match et les versaillais qui
évolue en nationale 3 n'avait pas
atteint ce stade de la compétition
depuis 2011
ils ont montré un petit peu plus
d'expérience que nous la source ce mot
sur ce genre de match qui sont quand
même important donc j'ai tiré un peu
plus d'expérience après je pense pas
qu'on avait quelque chose à leur envier
que ce soit techniquement ou
physiquement
une ou deux erreurs défensives mans qui
nous ont coûté des buts on était puni
froidement mais voilà c'est la vérité du
32e de finale de coupe de france de ce
niveau là et là dessus il faut il faut
apprendre le tracé du paris-nice la
course cycliste qui veut surprendre les
spectateurs a été dévoilée mercredi pour
la 11e année consécutive la course
s'élancera des yvelines et c'est la
ville de plaisir qui a été choisie pour
accueillir la première étape départ le
dimanche 8 mars pour une boucle de 154
km deuxième étape le lendemain en
partant de chevreuse la commune sera 19e
la 19e ville des yvelines être village
départ de l'épreuve
et cette semaine pour notre rubrique ça
s'est passé nous revenons sur
l'assassinât de clarissa jean-philippe
je ne peux les serres municipales puis à
montrouge par le terroriste amedi
polybel dit le 8 janvier 2015
au lendemain des attaques contre la
rédaction de charlie hebdo cinq ans
après les hommages se poursuivent pour
ne pas oublier
[Musique]
cérémonie émouvante ce samedi à
carrières sous poissy un square a été
renommé au nom de clarissa jean-philippe
la policière tuée à mourouj paramédics
coulibaly et lui famille et riverains
sont venus lui rendre un dernier hommage
c'est très importantes comme ça on
oublie pas un rêve dans les mémoires et
c'était à lui de beaux discours et c'est
vraiment touchant il est et restera dans
notre coeur est un grand vide
il ya grand vide pour ça c'était une
collègue un ami et un grand vide ils ont
fait de belles choses pour que la raison
elle serait contente elle est contente
je pense l'air de jeu se situe au pied
de l'immeuble où vivait la jeune
policière dont le quartier des bords de
seine un endroit qu'elle appréciait tout
particulièrement la mère de la jeune
fille qui a fait le déplacement de la
martinique avec son fils se souvient
comme elle habitait là épicé de repli si
qu'elle faisait son footing elle faisait
tout elle venait pour se ressourcer de
la matinée qu'elle voit pas encore
qu'elle voyait pas ma cousine et moi on
est venu avec elle et nous emmener
partout on a vécu ça et puis là je crois
qu'ils ont fait ça c'est comme si je
revois ma fille assise au parc
un an après sa disparition tragique le
meurtre de clarissa dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
relance le débat sur l'armement des
policiers municipaux
une mesure annoncée par françois
hollande quelques jours après les
attentats du 13 novembre
aujourd'hui on a des terroristes qui
sont prêts à tuer tuer de manière
gratuite avec des armes de guerre
donc forcément a minima il faut armer
nos policiers il était temps que le
pouvoir politique donne cet ordre
clarissa jean-philippe fait partie des 6
48 victimes du terrorisme qui ont trouvé
la mort en 2015 sur le sol français
[Musique]
sortons des yvelines direction l'essonne
pour les deuxièmes assises de l'islam en
essonne représentants du culte musulman
et préfectures ont signé une charte de
l'islam de la république
reportage de nos confrères via grand
paris l'islam en débat en essonne pour
les deuxièmes assises le besoin de
carrés musulmans dans les cimetières et
les conditions d'abattage lors de l'aïd
el-kébir fêtes musulmanes sont en tête
des sujets traités à l'occasion du
rendez vous annuel
aujourd'hui les carrés musulmans des
fois ne sont pas assez grands pour
accueillir parce qu'aujourd'hui la
troisième la quatrième génération ne
veulent plus aller se frotter au pays de
leurs ancêtres
parce qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans sont
à part entière français imams
représentants des mosquées et personnels
de la préfecture de l'essonne ont
profité des assises annuelles de l'islam
pour signer la charte de l'islam de la
république
un document qui selon les signataires
permet d'avancer les projets musulmans
plus sereinement dans une république
laïque
les représentants de mosquées et les
imams déclarent partager des valeurs de
la république dans toutes leurs
dimensions d'égalité des sexes par
exemple la non discrimination la volonté
de porter de promouvoir les valeurs de
la république en tout lieu et de faire
prévaloir les principes de la république
laïque sur toute autre considération
c'est pour nous une base extrêmement
solide y compris sur la formation des
imams qui peut associer des institutions
publiques notamment pour rappeler les
règles dans lesquelles les cultes
exercent leur activité sur le territoire
national créé un cimetière pour
augmenter l'espace dédié au carré
musulman à brétigny en essonne et l'une
des pistes évoquées à l'occasion de
cette réunion
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte avec les
images qui vous donneront fin lundi
c'était l'épiphanie et vous dégusterez
très certainement la galette des rois ce
week-end retour de l'actualité locale
dès lundi sur tv 78
[Musique]
j'aime la galette
savez vous que nous
allez bien dubé
très
la laine ne l'est
[Musique]
là